you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on HS org and
I just got paired up playing a 15-2 game
I guess we will start out with efore
okay we have a French defense
let's see
haven't I done yet lots let's try d4 for
a start I could try to take it into a
Kings Indian attack but let's go
straight in for our French and now I'm
not going to capture just kind of
deciding do I want to go for a win of
our or something a bit more
positional it could turn positional with
the win of our very strategic play um
yeah let's welcome Bishop to b4 tyrant
has wished me hello oh we have a capture
so we're not going to have the bishop
before line okay my experience with this
is hmm what to say I kind of find it
hard to obtain some advantage for white
with this line
probably just Knight to f3 likes just
preparing to challenge my knight on e4
so I'm wondering how exactly to go about
deploying my pieces
is there really a better square for my
king Knight
probably not hmm yeah let's just get him
there and then we'll decide what to do
once my knight is challenged I don't
know if I want to capture or just
reinforce I feel like I want to maybe
just capture I know it's helping this
guy but hmm I might want to this is a
strike that black is looking forward to
and so I don't know if I want this
Knight here to support it this is pretty
much going to happen that I don't
believe I'm able to prevent this I could
look into Knight takes Knight takes
Bishop e3 but I'm not even guaranteed
that it's preventing c5 there are some
ideas connected with c5 and a queen a
five-wits check
so the queen is indoor indirectly we can
say influencing c-51 c5 is in what more
to say
oh also Knight takes may takes Bishop
III my bishop can be struck out with
Knight d5 orgy for which I don't think
is such a good move so let's consider
Bishop d3 or just capturing the knight
on f6 oh I could also play Bishop g5
yeah Bishop g5 is another move I guess I
I guess I could do Bishop to g5 hmm I
wonder if castling queenside is an idea
you know certainly a moment for me to
think this one through but I want to try
to get some some setup I'm comfortable
with if I Castle queenside this
this move is still gonna happen I think
it's too much of an open position I
don't see it beneficial to go Queen side
with the C file opening up my King's
gonna be here I'll need another move so
do I just try just go Kings side hmm
yeah maybe you know I'm gonna focus more
on King side development and maybe I
don't even declare my dark square bishop
just yet I think he might lag in
development some I could insert a check
I think I've done this before
provoking c6 or maybe if the bishop
blocks I can strike at it with Knight
here later mm-hmm
or even
to be 5 and then Queenie - if they block
with the bishop I'm gonna give that a go
I don't know just kind of what to say
poking around some on c6 I'm prepared to
drop my Bishop back to d3 one thing I
can say is that I don't want my bishop
here this is a half-open file so one day
I want my rook here and so therefore I
don't want a piece obstructing my Brooks
view so they're playing c6 and I imagine
soon they're gonna be playing c5 next
yeah let's go here I have d4 covered I'm
pointing at age 7 I'm expecting c5
before the bishop moves so in the event
I capture it can recapture in one move
not doing that interesting so I kind of
view that as should c5 be played and I
capture a little time has been lost one
tempo okay
what about just castles straight away I
don't see anything wrong with that Queen
e2 is also appealing let's go with
castles first yeah I can't do without
castles let's get that in everybody
knows I'm going to castle let's do the
move that everybody knows I'm going to
make
and retain some options with this guy
hmm as black uh hmm I move worries me a
little bit because not because of the
pressure here I have that covered but
I'm wondering if black is actually
considering going Queen side
saddle our what did I just say
a more solid structure saddle I guess
saddle means solid structure a more
solid structure is to go at c3 and then
I have no worries of ever you know I
don't have to watch over d4 if there's
peace pressure c4 is a bit more
committal a bit more of a dynamic try
maybe that is an idea
about hmm yeah I'm gonna go in for that
I think this is useful to have some nice
nice control over d5
there's no 95 here this is a square
maybe an I can look to hop do a couple
different ways really
my phone is trying to fishing pull me
Wow okay well probably just a ch3 huh
it's a bit of an odd move all right
gonna have to show me are you really
just gonna hop into a ch2 or play h5 I
don't think this is something that's
really such a good idea
still playing without the queenside
pieces still uncle and two moves away
before I have connection between I so
what's the big idea with this if the
knight retreats it's just a waste so I
guess they have to justify that move now
9h - I just played as if that's not even
a threat rook to e1 let the knight take
me and I get to recapture and develop
I'm expecting age 5 otherwise this isn't
just this moved in here doesn't make any
sense
and I'm not so sure that h5 is even
working can they get away with taking
the night because I could take and after
the recapture I could go here still a
little bit scary but I think I'd be able
to defend suppose h5 takes takes 95
takes takes takes again Queen is here
threatening mate
now that the H files peeled open without
my nighttime board my queen controls h5
so I could defend against H - its g3 I
have you know queen h5 covered and I'm
soon to offset the rook I believe with
King g2 rook h1 ideas
does their chewing on it
I imagine that's what they're
considering h5 okay now they hopped
right into h2 okay
as mentioned I believe I just go here
get on play it as if this night isn't
even here what more yeah I feel like I'm
I know it's a bit of a stretch but I
feel like I'm close to winning in a way
I feel like this is a strong advantage
for me development wise
okay uh-huh yeah let's just get out of
the way occupy half open file
notice one two three four moves with the
night this was a useful move
let's recapture one move away from
completing development this is
unprotected okay how can I try to put
this advantage this lead in development
to use hmm
well black is going to struggle some to
get these pieces working so I'm
considering
I'm considering something like c5 Bishop
f4 Bishop e5 or actually first this
Bishop f4 queen d8 rook a to d1 hmm the
queen is on da how'd it hardly getting
the bishop working
I think some kind of rook up
her stuff is not really working I know
he's really backward
um c5 Bishop f4 Bishop e5 if he's ever
challenged with the bishop here I could
be welcome to an exchange and I could
try to key in on d6
you know it just feels like I should be
able to put to use this this advantage
time I'm gonna be gaining more time even
no two bishops potentially pointing at
the King and I think this is helping me
much breaking it open like this because
I help the bishop
let's give c5 a shot Bishop h2 is just
restricting the Queen so let's follow
through I should always keep a watchful
eye on a capture directly followed up
with some check with the Queen or
directly a queen move one of these two
moves this with one of these two or one
of the two Queen moves first let's start
with this move get another piece working
right Queen takes d4 is no good and I
thought they might do that so I'm
considering actually
either Bishop d6 first I'm wondering if
the rook is better placed on this square
this square mm-hmm there may be some
tricks like I could somehow take
advantage of s7 a little less protection
on f7 if the bishop if the rook is on EI
hmm tough to say I don't think I'll be
able to work that one out mmm let's
consider hang on yeah oh and I'm gonna
do this I think my rook is or my bishop
once it arrives here you know I don't
think that the rook could really being a
good piece on e85 I anticipate
eventually going here with my bishop
this is a flat-out loss double attack
against the bishop in h7 so this is a
really strong piece I have a deficient
pawn I can also look forward to playing
B for stopping Queen a5 and preparing to
meet a5 with b5 yeah let's do that let's
see how they work around my dark square
Bishop if it's challenged I'm gonna back
up here they're still playing without
these two also now this is a possibility
rook lifts are starting to become pretty
interesting if this move has ever played
okay it's not I don't think damaging the
structure is so great how about I just
get on with a 4 B 5 Queen can't go too
far then I'll take here you know if
there's ever a capture my rook is soon
going to be glued on d6 and he'll never
be removed and if he is I'll have a
connected passed pawn very very deep in
blacks position
oh let's see at the 4-minute mark let's
pull the trigger on something huh
hey for it is
I gotta make some move
in exchange isn't that losing I think
that's a losing move huh I could just
exchange Queens take the bishop if they
take like this I'll have it three versus
two
I don't know I definitely have an
advantage here I'm I could exchange
Queens they take with the pawn I'm
taking here I'll be able to get here
with a pin the King I'll have a flight
square it'll be a damaged structure I'm
expecting Queen takes Queen to be met
with see takes mm-hmm seems like I'll
have a pretty good clamp over the
position
my pounds are going to get really deep
on the queenside
Bishop to e4 as well but I'm gonna be a
bit more practical with so little time
now I'm gonna try this descending which
is a little bit of a pull for me got a
play with the C this is I'm pretty sure
flat out loss
so they're thinking about it I'll Kyle
can I win the rook there should be five
not quite I can't control these two
squares with the bishop let's start with
this let's keep pushing three versus two
their majority lies in the center two
versus one interesting moment mm yeah
probably just take with the rook huh or
not hang on the pawn is actually
interesting I don't want to get them I
don't want black to allow some kind of
roller my bishop would be a fine block
hater of a passed pawn I'm gonna go with
this guy and one day I'd like to get my
King on d4
also he's gonna need some support isn't
he okay
they're preparing a six trying to meet
trying to get this guy think I want to
play a five let's go with a five got a
defend and a little bit of a pin good
play I have an interesting move if this
is played I think a six I could consider
this move let's start with this
two-minute mark this guy's been flying
got a defense
for king of two King III King D for yep
I'm not taking him I'm thinking more
about King position before I'm thinking
about pawn grabbing I think also he's
just poisoned
kingi three
for and this will free up one of my
rooks once my king is on d4 if they push
here I think I can actually sneak in
like that and pick him up
this is a very strong pawn I have space
in the center and on the Queen side the
rooks well this rook at least has no
move on a six I think I can try and I
believe I will play C six and meet B
take C with B six connecting Pat
connected past pawn they'll have an
extra pawn but I'll be able to maintain
control over c5 definitely and this pond
may end up one anyhow with the bishop at
some point I guess that's what they're
lining up let's improve the King
I don't want to allow a 6 B 6 and then
the bishop to kind of mmm be glued into
c6 I don't want this to be a reliable
home for the bishop
okay well easy does it easy does it here
let's not allow one pun restrict two of
mine age four was a threat I was saying
my king
and run up to d4 but because you really
want to go there right now I think this
is the correct idea not to be too quick
you know not to be too focused on hey
let's get the King to the center let's
address the little ideas black has as
well now we're definitely going here to
rule out any possibility of a pawn push
okay so they're holding off one of my
rooks is free I'm going to move this one
if any so that he remains protected how
would I play here just did let's see
what he does it's maybe I'm threatening
to play a six now see if I could get
black to bite with a six c6 takes B 5
Sumi B 6
now they're holding off so should I go
straight in for this
if I play over here my king I'm afraid
of the my king being struck out um maybe
I could actually win the rook now no hmm
not quite
v6a takes a takes rook c6 um-hmm less
than a minute let's make a passing move
I think now I'm threatening v6 for sure
to end up winning a rook let's see if
they come back over to the a file I
don't know
let's see if I could get them to bite
want to see their we'll come back over
here I'm gonna try be six probably spend
too much time on that last one I missed
my opportunity to play b6 straight away
hmm
okay happy to see that because now I can
actually look into playing this move I
don't have to react just yet over here
let's just go back here have a little
bit more coordination I guess they're
giving in the rook another move ah that
interesting
there they were sidestepping that little
idea okay I mean I'm gonna try this I
have another another direction I could
be going in this is still a potential
threat or even some sacrifice with this
pawn running my bishop is a tremendous
piece rook a to f8 and then f5 hmm let's
see try to open up another side of the
board 16 seconds
Bishop to b5 you know let's think I want
to take with the pawn you know I also
look out for hmm well I'm going to do
this my rook is super active this pawn
remains a beast
can't contest the rook
I feel like black is playing without
their Bishop could hunt down there h5
pawn at some point it's turn over here
the rook steps up I have this move how
about let's just do some time gainers
hmm
I just call it let's do this take some
action hmm
Oh actually I could do this because in
the end I could sacrifice here this is a
winning shot
rooks and then flight and then play
Bishop takes on a six
Fisher could come back here to defend
against any threat drop my bishop back
here
I've also just kind over there
got a take and now I'm just pushing
through
I think I'm stopping those puns
I hope I'm stopping those puns
yes I am my bishop stops this guy
okay he's trying to burn me on time I
got the increment though okay they
resigned hmm tough game I thought I
probably could have done something more
direct
I'm sure the computer will point out
something much more direct on the
queenside some type of break but as was
played out I mean I didn't have to it's
one of those positions where there isn't
you shouldn't feel some sense of a rush
cuz hmm it's kind of under an under
control position you know the the
different ways it can open up the
different type of pawn breaks that are a
possibility are not really beneficial to
black so just kind of skimming through
certainly spent a lot of time in the
opening don't know if this was best but
we kind of just get a bit of a playable
position I was expecting c5 as soon as I
played into d3
and sure enough c5 is a top move there
are as you could see here 76 games
played with that master level games
so this is a top move c5 just played
some of the top moves takes bishop takes
and then getting on with castles castles
Queenie - very natural square Bishop g5
and just kind of getting a feel for how
the game would play out yeah open
position but it's it's tough - I don't
know could see it a lot of trades
happening both rooks maybe being being
exchanged with there being only one open
file it's quite common to have happen
okay yeah I thought see five right away
I played c6 and Bishop outright or on
this what move eight castles Queen c7
you know I could play c4 or c3 but I
want to be a bit more aggressive and I
think this is kind of going in the wrong
direction you know we just look at it
well I mean the event the evaluations
already popping up you know it's already
about a pawn advantage for me a bit too
strong in game when I'm saying I feel
like I'm winning in a way but it's I
don't know like in if it was like a
computer versus computer type thing I
feel like the computer would be able to
as white just beat black this is like a
strong enough advantage you know c5 grab
some space and I have my ax and d6 I
know the the drawback here is that
there's now a hole on d5 but there's
also a hole on d6 and in the event of
something like suppose this type of
structural change occurs this is what I
was voicing during the game this is now
enormous so there's I'm benefiting in
multiple ways here if this if this
structural change came about one that is
related to space and the other that is
related to having the better of the two
bishops and I've rook on d6 there he
goes and there he will stay you know if
ever captured connected past pawn those
King and pawn end games all of a sudden
er now in my favor didn't quite have
that happen where's there maybe some
improvement maybe I could do without the
Queen exchange I don't know I guess I
could do this and force the Queen back
yeah that's right
maybe I should have done that right well
I think my reasoning was I was I'd like
about the three minute mark around this
point so I felt like I'd be able to play
faster if the Queen's are off but
objectively I think this is
the best move forces this back otherwise
I win the bishop and then I could get on
with this really putting a lot of heat
on the queenside
to bishops hitting at both directions if
ever captured then I have the d6 square
this has to be really really good for me
so I could have considered Bishop before
I went into the endgame and I think it's
important I think this no this is the
last structural change if I'm taking
with the rook they kind of get their
majority working you know their majority
starts to be felt let's say whereas by
taking with the pawn and trying to
maintain this pawn here the majority
isn't isn't really felt is it and well
the other way to look at it is I'm
opening up this square for later on my
king and this is exactly where he would
like to be in the endgame and he he got
there
so an important moment I think I think I
did that was what I was going to do but
I had to see that I don't want them to
be able to show that their majority is
something
taking with upon I have to defend for a
little bit but soon there's the lot this
little role reversal biking improves now
I just need my King in the rook and one
of my rooks is free
let me see this is the one thing I just
want to look at could I have played b6
right away what kept me from this was
this continuation I wanted to do this
move thinking I'm trapping the rook but
he's now unprotected in there's this
move and I think I'm right about that I
don't think I could do that that's what
I that's what I wanted to do and this is
why I was trying to get black to have
their two rooks here when my rook was on
this square
you know so I came over here I'm kind of
doing a nothing move and even in this
position right now suppose they did this
now it's different
I could play B six takes takes rook here
Bishop Bishop to b5 is working rook
takes pawn I can recapture cuz my king
is now defending the rook that's what I
was trying to pull off with minimal time
but they didn't quite bite they played
that which I don't think is helping
black um if anything maybe this is a
better try striking here and looking to
open up this file for the rooks but this
is only helping me in a way maybe black
can view it as I'm fixing upon on a
light square but this is really a long
way off and I don't think the benefit is
I think it's really benefiting me more
than black because now I have an
additional pawn break in that of f5 and
sure enough we saw that take shape I
could go in another direction
I didn't want to take here because I was
fearful of getting too simplified I
could have tried for this sneaking in
here
I don't believe black would have allowed
that they would probably try to plug
this square up and probably well I don't
know how exactly to assess this it's
definitely still a bit tricky yeah I
don't know but this is that's basically
what I wanted to avoid in the reason for
any kind of shutting down the queenside
and yeah got some play on the F file and
a timely break a few passing move time
burning moves and I got this shot in
there and it's just winning I don't
think I missed anything actually right
here I was a bit worried of not the
capture right away Oh actually the other
thing is if the pawn pushes I could just
take with the King my bishop is now
there to stop these guys yeah I guess
this is still winning no matter what
yeah came there yeah my king stops these
two my bishop will be responsible for
stopping this one in time and he runs
okay
well let's have a look at it with the
engine and just kind of see when it has
to say or see from the graph it's pretty
it's a small advantage mm-hmm well it
starts to be something really right
around move 10 when when black went in
for this little Knight journey into h2
so a lot of time is lost here you know 1
2 3 4 and I'm really never
inconvenienced by any of those moves you
know this is what I mean by that is h3
is desirable anyway I'm stopping the
threat and I view this as also a flight
square one day so it's useful it's a
useful reaction and I'm just helped
development wise c5 is fine
this idea is fine Bishop d6 probably
spent
much time right around here trying to be
too exact about is the rook better here
here is it really worth doing this first
but I guess I there works
keep the Bishop on and just get rolling
here huh
+3 let me put on the arrows I missed
something here
Oh rook there huh I was pointing out
Bishop b4 you know this works as well
with b5 hmm takes is being suggested
I see the idea if Queen takes I could
take on c6
a bishop move that couldn't there's not
a safe bishop move to connect rooks whoa
what a shot that is so if I took they
have to take with the pawn and that's
not what's something you want to do with
the Queen still on board
ah that would have been nice to spot
so I could have done this with a
captured diverting the Queen away and
then we take here Queen takes Queen
recaptured the bishop and I'm up upon
still have that majority rolling an even
bigger majority then ah okay so I took I
push is that the correct way to do it
recapture wants to go with the rook same
evaluation with the pond about the same
yeah I really didn't want to allow this
well I allow this kind of stuff yeah I
think it's unnecessary to to do this I
felt there's more control with and
having a pond there which is a bit
debatable in other situations because
this is now giving black a connected
past pond so I have to be sure that I
could take good control for that because
I don't want him off and running
whenever black wants to unleash him
let's just say so I took what the pond
and yeah it's not a and it's tricky for
a black but you know once my king is on
d4 big trouble
I could go with a six right away well
kept me with from playing a six was I
guess on a capture I didn't want to have
to even cope with any threat against my
pawns no
you that huh that's really not so much
pressure I got d6 these guys are really
controlling a lot of squares huh and
black really doesn't have many squares
to work with they have three pieces and
how many squares seven to work with
these are cut off
okay I could have gone in for a 6v6 c6
connected past pond and then we come
over here and look to open up another
side of the board okay and h5 really
isn't helping
b6 anything really missed I don't think
so just holding the advantage in the
last the last break here
b6 I guess they have they have to play
here and keep the bishop controlling b7
that way I don't have this move could
take now and we could have all these
exchanges oops
these exchanges and this isn't working
he's covering it so this is probably an
even endgame still still a little bit
tricky I don't know yeah and I don't see
I don't see how I'm able to make
progress here you know that's not that's
not going to be enough but yeah as soon
as the bishop dropped back there that's
a that's a game loser
they had a tribe rook to g8 there what
kind of eye what could I have done
different here
instead of running because when I push
rook g8 so instead of pushing it's
calling for this hmm
Rock g8 okay six rook over whoo
well that's different huh g5 huh g8 and
now this I guess looking to enter in the
seventh yeah this game
sophisticated and I could even do this
stuff hm-hmm
strong King position you know do a do a
king physique in comparison if there's
ever a capture its a passed pawn and now
here comes the king I have an aggressive
Bishop if he's not careful I take this
guy out and he runs like in the game
okay
well interesting game my opponent put me
under some pressure there certainly with
the clock but I think it really the what
started to really how to say I kind of
went in the wrong direction with this ID
of the knight move first
it's really wasted a lot of time this
little King maneuver and I wasn't really
inconvenienced by it
and had no you could you could easily
see this time advantage just go away if
you're not playing well enough if you're
not making some some good moves but you
know I think this was a nice idea to
just have my Bishop planted here and
just expand over here on the Queen side
you know Bishop to e4 would have been a
move and reply to Queen d5 rook to e4 I
didn't even have a look at rook to e4
what's the idea at that let me kind of
make a I don't know oh well I'm
threatening the bishop right now
that's the thing there's no Queen takes
Queen so I'm on this if the bishop backs
up okay yeah now now we're seeing a lot
of issues here army this is a different
story I'm playing with one two three
four attacking pieces and well they're
playing with two pieces out of it well
they're not playing with two other
pieces the Queen side is doing nothing
so yeah I could have
gone for a little rook lift which
earlier I was saying I didn't think it
was the right idea I think right around
here before I played c5 I was
considering or ruling out really
something like rookie four over here
it just didn't didn't feel like I you
know I was in a position to do that but
with the center a bit more lockdown and
let's say this position as soon as
there's no c5 pawn break or ePHI pawn
break now with the center bit more under
control these ideas with rook to e4 are
something that I should be thinking
about I guess okay well interesting game
out of the French defense Rubinstein
variation as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you